okay another question that came in um
if trump loses to biden in a few days
how will trump trump is justify it
this is a great question because you
have you know just look at our youtube
comments look at the emails and tweets
that i get
david you're gonna cry on election day
when joe biden loses
trump's got this thing wrapped up biden
has no chance
trump's gonna win easily all of this
different stuff and i am not saying
anything other than the polls look good
for biden but it could go either way
so i i have taken a position that
is based on the facts no trumpist can
know
that donald trump is going to win and
indeed if donald trump loses
they're not going to say hey you know
what biden ran the better campaign
and more people wanted biden to win
biden won that's not what trumpists are
going to say
they have such cognitive dissonance that
you are going to see them come up with
things you can imagine and things you
can't imagine some trumpets
if biden wins will say biden cheated and
by cheated they might mean
stuff with absentee ballots they might
mean
uh manipulating voting machines they who
facebook who knows what biden cheated is
going to be one
story that we are going to hear um okay
biden won but only because of the fake
news media that promoted him at every
opportunity you're gonna see a lot of
that
people going after the media saying the
media helped joe biden
win you were going to hear biden
didn't really win trump didn't really
lose not from the standpoint
of cheating but from the standpoint of
it is just a fake story trump really won
even though it's being reported that joe
biden won you're going to see some of
that
you will then see it's sort of like a
the the
five stages of grief a denial anger
bargaining dab duh denial angle bar
d what's the depression and then
acceptance
you will start to see some people say
trump didn't want to win anyway
trump didn't they're going to be
rationalizing and trump did trump had
his four years
he didn't have to do this he had a great
life beforehand he's a rich guy
now he's going to go and make america
great by starting some tv network or who
knows what you are going to see that
absolutely for sure
and then you are also going to see some
people who say covid
trump's already been laying the
groundwork for it saying
we had the greatest economy i had great
popularity
and then the virus hit the plague came
in from china as donald trump says
and while if trump had handled it
properly he would be sailing to
reelection
we've seen when a world leader deals
with the virus well
they sail to re-election look at jacinda
ardern in new zealand as an example
trump could have done that but you will
see people say
100-year pandemic just got hit with the
plague
and that is why donald trump lost
otherwise he would have won it doesn't
really count as a loss they will say
i want to hear from you what other
explanations
are we going to hear from trumpists and
some we won't hear anything from
because they will disappear we will
never hear from them again
they will get off the social media
retweeting a fake news
they will stop doing all they're just
going to disappear we're never going to
the ones that are really just
embarrassed are going to disappear many
will come up with excuses let me know
what you think those excuses will be
we have a great bonus show for you today
the last friday bonus show
before the 2020 election senate election
congressional election presidential
election
many ballot measures local races so much
friday bonus show today and then it is
election week i will see you then